Allophone and minimal parents.
You're going to need those concepts to
start examining the phonology of Latin
American Spanish.
We'll start with minimal pairs,
which will allow us to document
the phoneme inventory of Spanish.
Such an inventory should contain
all major contrasting phonemes.
Here are five words that differ minimally
be so basal basle puzzle puzzle.
We can infer that e a r
o n o r vowel phonemes.
If we compare to other words, we'd find
that this holds up other minimal pairs.
Confirm that these five vowels are
distinct from one another and that there
isn't a sixth or a seventh foul beyond
these five that contrasts with them.
Next we'll move on to diphthongs Spanish
diphthongs start or end with the high
vowels so he or Ooh,
here we'll find examples of free variation
since the diphthongs sometimes have a
short vowel e or Ooh, but other times
have a more restricted glide. Yeah,
or what Gwyn that or Quinta qual or
quant CN or seeing the Gfsi or Gaussi.
If we turn to focus on the consonants,
we find many minimal pairs demonstrating
that Spanish as far more consonant
phonemes than vowel phonemes and
if we keep comparing minimal pairs,
we'll have a list of how many and what
kind of consonant phonemes Spanish has.
At that point we can drop a table of all
those consonants arranged by place of
articulation,
manner of articulation and voicing.
I'm sure you remember those terms
from the IPA for language learning,
but if not head back to
those lessons for review.
Now we have a tidy answer
to the basic question.
How many different sounds of Spanish
have we answered that by finding minimal
pairs,
Spanish words that differ by only one
sound lead us to think that these are all
different sounds in Spanish.
Phonemes contrast with each other. At
least they did an arm, minimal pairs,
but what about sounds that don't contrast
as you listen more closely to Latin
American Spanish,
you'll notice that the pronunciation of
many of these phonemes varies depending
on context.
You'll hear and pronounced
aim in embodies,
but not in.
In Hispana you'll hear Gusto,
but not a disaster.
But you'll hear gas
asto and not get Gusto.
You'll hear dwelling, but not the
way late. And you'll hear ms Wally,
but not mid dwelling.
You'll hear Baca and not Laka,
but you'll hear Lavacca and not blah.
On the other hand,
you'll hear some speakers say Kylie
and others say Kylie. Some will say,
may Jamo and others made jam and
some Mucho, but others Musha.
What do these allophones suggest about
the pronunciation system of Spanish?
Come back next time to expand
your understanding of phonology.
Yeah.